most people are burn out at work not
because the job is hard but because they
have no friends in fact I think most of
the studies show that people love their
job if they have one good friend at work
and even in our community at mosaic one
of the things I talk about all the time
is I mean I have a person on our team
whose entire responsibility is to make
sure that everyone's living in community
on the staff and that's his principal
job because I I know that hard work
can actually be exhilarating if you feel
you have
friends and easy work can feel
overwhelming if you're all alone so I
don't you know I mean I don't know the
whole dynamic but I would say burnout
has nothing to do with how hard the job
is but how alone she feels